SEND FIREMEN ON THE BACK AND BE
THE CONTENT-1 WITH DOES  Steve:
SECOND ASSIST.
HE
GOOD AND HE SIGNALED PUSHED HEL
BUCK INTO HOLLY BOCK.
IT TO
CAPITALS.
BARKOV
AND GIROOVER 500, DAVE LOWRY,
SUCH START AND A COACHE STRONG
TWICE.
>> Steve: JUST KEEP IT OUT OF
NATE SCHMIDT HAMMERS ONE.
THE PUCK DOWN LOW AND WHEELER A
EHLERS ONE.
>> THE DUCLAIAIE SLOT.
HERE COMES HUBERDEAU  A. FOR GU
FORSLING.
HE A PREMIUM.  AT 4-0. NOW FORS
THE REDLINE AND
LINE  THE
FLOOR FOR THE PANTHERS IS THE T
WORKING.
LAST MAN OFF THE ICE YESTERDAY
SCHOOL.
COMES GIVES THE PANTHERS
THEIR SIXTH GOAL OF THE GAME
STARTED WITH A QUICK BREAK OUT.
THE PANTHERS JUMP ON THAT LOOST
AND BARKOV